my name is Rebecca black and I sang at
the song Friday this is that story it
all started in 2010 I just finished up
at the seventh alright agent so I was a
whopping 13 years old I grew up being a
huge musical leader kid I was that girl
that was obsessed with glee and tried to
sing the songs in my room I auditioned
for everything that I could it was my
home that was where I felt safe
throughout moving schools and I don't
know trying to figure out what I wanted
to do going back into eighth grade I had
noticed that a girl in my grade I was
friends with had done this like music
video was sort of a thing she shot it at
the school it was a little cute song and
she had friends in it I was like oh
that's a cool opportunity to like try
something new get experience and see
what I liked so I asked this girl like
hey how did you do that
she had mentioned that it was through
this little company it was this thing
that like produced these songs for kids
like my age teenagers so I brought it up
to a mom one day like on a whim fully
expecting her to say no my mom's a
single mom so it's not like this stuff
is just pouring out of the sky but to my
surprise she said yeah we emailed the
company met up with them that was my
first time ever even seeing what any of
that looks like they basically said we
can write you a song put you in a music
video if you get a hundred thousand
views you can start making money per
minute but at that point I was like okay
there's no way that this little thing is
gonna get any sort of attention so
whatever like I just want the experience
they send me a song and the first song
was a song called superwoman about
some boys superwoman and at that point I
had just finished up my first
relationship that lasted three days and
I broke up with him because I was too
afraid to talk to him so that clearly
wasn't going to be the song that I was
going to say I asked him to send me
another one because I just didn't really
feel comfortable
they sent me a song called it's Friday
and it was a cute little song of like
waking up going to school and I was like
yeah I do that this is this is it it
wasn't even really about like what the
song was about or planning for this big
career debut because that just doesn't
happen to me so I went in I did the
whole feel of a recording process
learning what it's even like I was kind
of bad I knew that the music video was
coming up in a couple weeks but I didn't
even hear the song until I got on set
for the music video I had no idea what
really to expect
it felt honestly kind of like we were
all going over to my dad's house to do a
project things were just kind of
happening around me and it wasn't really
like this big glamorous ordeal or
anything like that I had gone to a
forever 21 I got my outfit the day
before I had invited a few of my friends
I thought that would be a lot more fun
than hiring anyone to like come hang out
I remember doing that performance shot
that's like on top of this little grass
patch not knowing what to do with my
arms so I think if you watch the video
like I'm just digging and dancing like
this for the whole time which god it was
a fun day but also just kind of like
okay this is what we're doing a month
went by and honestly I had no idea where
it was I was just kind of like thinking
about it every once in a while like I
wonder when I'll when I'll see you
February 10th of 2011
I got a little notification from the
company's website that the video was
live
I was really weirdly nervous I think I
watched it alone for my first time what
I really remember doing was afters maybe
see it one time going to my dad and
being like dad it's out and watching it
together and my dad and I just being
like
yeah I told my friends that were in the
video at school for a while like that
was it I would get like one or two
people at school that be like hey it's
Friday I wouldn't really check it that
much online I know that over the first
month it had like maybe three thousand
views or something one day which
literally was a Friday I was on my way
home from school and I got another
little notification from the website hey
this sucks but you're gonna be famous
and I think they said that it was on a
website called tosh point-o when I saw
that I was just really confused I don't
even think I told my mom or anything I
like one straight to my room and was
like what's going on I went to the video
and it definitely had three times the
amount of views that it had a few days
ago comments were starting to come a bit
more and they were definitely all making
fun of me making fun of the song that
immediately put the biggest pit in my
stomach I've probably ever had I think
at that point I was just like mom help
she brought me into her room and I think
I just started crying I mean it's not
that I was protecting this thing as my
like prized most beautiful creative
thing I've ever made in my life but it
was me and that was my face and that was
my name people were making fun of my mom
got on the phone with a people put the
video up and they asked me if I wanted
to take it down we could put it away
this never happened it's just a blip and
move on one thing that I just could not
shake within myself was like no I don't
want to put this down it's so much more
embarrassing I think there was also this
like fire in myself I'm not gonna let
these people win that easy will bubble
bubble bubble whoa I've been through
this enough you want to fight let's go
let's do this a few days go by and
now at over million views that weekend
my family and I were just kind of
watching it build more and more rapidly
my name was trending worldwide I
remember I was walking down the street
on Twitter and I was like oh my god Nick
Jonas just saying my song at his show
what I remember my first day back at
school was probably one of the weirdest
days of my life when like recess came
about all of these people just like
blocked my way because they were so
curious with all of that going on my
parents were trying to figure out how to
handle like all of the incoming stuff
now Good Morning America wants to talk
about something and I just got asked to
do The Tonight Show with Jay Leno I
don't even think I knew what a manager
was at that time of course they were
coming to my parents saying we're gonna
change your life and my mommy and do all
these things at this point as well I had
stopped going to the school I was at
public school and I stepped into home
schooling to finish the year I come from
a family of doctors who expect nothing
about literally greatness from you and I
was getting all these crazy
opportunities you know spend the day
doing this and then spent a day going
and working with this person and doing
all of these crazy things
my grades were horrible on top of that
yeah kids were mean I'd walk down the
hallways and
it was just this like weird persnickety
like very few people were laughing with
me I was like this would all just be so
much easier if I could not be so nervous
about it all the time as much as like I
wanted to keep my friends and how much I
needed them at that point I think both
me and those friends cut each other off
because we were young and petty and yeah
I don't know if there's one person to
blame but I I think I isolated myself
like while also being isolated the
craziest thing about while all of this
was going on and all this like weird
attention was coming I got to do some of
the coolest things that I've ever done I
got to work with Katy Perry who at that
point was like my idol
not only just work with her but like
have her have my back I got to go to
award shows and Redcar friends and do
the whole thing I won a Teen Choice
Award hosting YouTube rewind and being
the number one googled thing that year
which is insane so 2011 definitely ended
up being the weirdest year of my life it
was one of the best and obviously one of
the worst and so life went on it was
kind of like what what happens now 2012
was one of the darkest years for me I
was 15 and I had no friends and I was
super alone and at that point like you
would think having like a team and all
these things makes everything so much
better but all it was were just people
who
didn't care to understand what I wanted
didn't want to hear it if anything that
was just interrupting their plan for who
I was going to be and when you're that
young no one should be telling you
anything like that you've got to figure
it out for yourself when I was 16 I
fired everyone in my team and my parents
were like you should go back to club
work school so I did and at that point I
started a YouTube channel and that was
one of the most freeing things I'd ever
done for myself because I got to talk I
wanted I was editing all my own stuff I
was making so many friends that loved
what I loved - and also covering things
and just I don't know I let myself fly
the first thing that I like really
released on my own was a few years ago
in 2016 and that was horrifying leading
up to it to have to put out so I was
like like this is something I actually
like it is real it is genuine it came
for me wrote written for me so now my
days look like me constantly writing
music and coming up with what is gonna
happen next I put out a song called
anyway this last year that I love so
much and has been really fun to do and
I'm just about to put out another song
called do you I know when I look back
when I'm you know hopefully old and I've
had a whole life that I can be like yeah
okay
I did that for myself I'm about to go on
tour this summer opening up it's my
first like real full-fledged music tour
I guess I'll see you around the internet
or maybe see you untoward bye
[Music]